okay so I really love yes that was Noah
Cyrus and lil zan just last month but
over Labor Day weekend they called it
quits word LaLanne accused Noah of
cheating on him Noah shut that down
though was saying it was this Charlie
puth meme that she texted him that
actually set him off if y'all think that
that meme is the reason I broke up with
Noah that is hilarious I broke up with
her because she was all over some of the
genes he's referring to this photo that
Noah herself posted with okay a music
producer Noah then shared her side of
the story claiming lil zan is the one
who cheated she posted this pic of him
circling what appears to be a hickey
from someone else and said she hadn't
seen her man and about a week it's hard
when no one understands like the time
zones and like the schedule and no one
really understands that more than him
and like we've like been crying in our
rooms together forever like about how
just were like exhausted together and
like it's cool to find somebody that
like understands I'm I totally gets
whenever you're like a little pissy but
part of the job
amid the breakup drama lows and also
revealed the music video for their song
live or die would not be released yep
the same song the pair raved over
together at the VMAs we roll live or die
and I put it out within a week and it's
like the reactions amazing yeah
everybody loves the chemistry you know
what I mean like it just works you know
got a lot of feelings for her
[Music]